[Music]  America with their majestic mountains  and amber waves of grain this Thursday  on our last livestream before our summer  hiatus we tackle a culture worth  appropriating with our salute to the  United States of America join us for  beer and barbecue as we mercilessly  critique and Mock the people who most  want to see America destroyed are a part  of the Avengers we're live-streaming the  first Democrat 2020 primary debate Biden  they're gonna put y'all back in cage  Bernie the American journalist spoke  about how bad the country is these  people are lining up food cut cake I  like to drink a cold brewski I'm just  like you and a bunch of other people we  all have to pretend that we've heard of  complete with a costume party guests  giveaways a likely banning in our  trademark ladder with credit drinking  game with rules to follow let's head  into our summer break with a bang  kicking off this Thursday June 27th at  8:30 p.m. Eastern